hey guys it's Tuesday June twenty eighth
I'm Mary and you're watching gamespot
news and today we got division dlc
problems free games of gold and
microsoft gets what they deserve let's
do it if you play the division don't
freak out or anything but the first paid
dlc underground has a few problems the
division was updated today to introduce
the game's first paid expansion
underground as well as the major weapon
balance changes and more unfortunately
for some players the rollout was not as
smooth as they would have liked some
players reported being unable to access
the underground content while
connectivity issues also popped up don't
freak out massive has provided
workaround instructions for some of the
problems it's investigating the
connectivity issues when Ubisoft massive
released patch 1.2 in May there were
also a few problems that the developer
responded to one of which involved
characters going missing whoops
underground features a new incursion
called Dragon's nest and new areas to
explore that offer endless replayability
that was a quote unquote Ubisoft has
achieved this by introducing what is
essentially randomly generated dungeons
like I said before the division also got
its 1.3 update today that introduced
major weapon balance changes and talent
recalibration system and fixes a bug
where the moon was upside down how would
you know underground and the 1.3 patch
are available on Xbox one and PC only
right now expansion lands on ps4 on
August second and the patch should be
out next week do you have an xbox one or
xbox 360 good news here's all the free
games you get with gold in July on the
Xbox one you're getting the crew which
is normally 30 bucks you get it June
sixteenth through July fifteenth you
also get one of my favorites the banner
saga 2 which is normally 20 bucks july
first to the 31st you're going to want
to pick that up finally you get
tumblestone which is normally twenty
bucks july 16th through august fifteenth
xbox 360 owners are getting rainbow six
vegas 2 which is normally 20 bucks july
first through 15th tron evolution which
is normally 15 bucks july 16th through
the 31st do you remember that xbox 360
games are playable through backwards
compatibility now while you wait for
july's titles to arrive be sure to grab
the remaining
16 titles before they're gone and today
we end with story time last week I was
playing overwatch when my computer shut
down and upgraded me to Windows 10 I was
mad I wanted to sue turns out another
woman was so mad she did sue and she got
10k out of it it's time to lawyer up
that's right a woman sued Microsoft over
windows 10 upgrade and ended up winning
10k according to a news report from the
seattle times the woman Terry Goldstein
of Sausalito California said a few days
after microsoft released windows 10
publicly in july the computer at her
travel agency business tried to download
it without her consent sound familiar
the update failed and her computer
slowed to a crawl crashing at times and
becoming unusable for days at a time
sound familiar and now for the quote
that speaks for all of us I had never
heard of Windows 10 Goldstein said no
one ever asked me if I wanted to update
sound familiar Goldstein attempted to
reach Microsoft's customer support
department to fix the problem but it
didn't work so she sued him she sought
compensation for lost wages and a cover
costs for a new computer and she won
earning $10,000 in the judgment it's
honestly the least they could do after
making people upgrade I consider this a
win for frustrated Windows 10 people
everywhere so that's it for today but
you're going to want to check back again
we're doing the news in house in San
Francisco for the whole week giving the
team in Australia a much-needed week off
I'll see you guys again tomorrow
you